what's next for healthcare for the
answer to that we turn to Jamelle Bouie
chief political correspondent at Slate
and a CBS News political contributor
he's in our Washington bureau jamel good
morning good morning so Reince Priebus
was seen as the guy that was sort of a
bridge he was obviously a part of that
Republican Party and a bridge to the
Capitol Hill for the president what does
that mean for legislation going forward
now that he's no longer with the White
House I think it's very much complicates
the Trump administration's efforts to
get legislation through Congress
Reince was the link to Republicans in
the hill as with Sean Spicer it seems
that the White House is pushing out
people who had those ties to the kind of
official Republican Party and without
them when you bring in through the
treatment of Jeff's Attorney General
Jeff Sessions as well
you begin to get the impression that the
White House is really burning its links
and burning its bridges with Republicans
on the hill and so President Trump
obviously has an agenda that he wants to
get through Congress but when you are
letting go the kinds of people who would
be able to make the connections make the
rebuild the relationships necessary to
move an agenda through Congress when
you're getting rid of those people
it's begins ticket become difficult to
see how one accomplishes that agenda and
on that agenda back to health care and
oh and the in the effort to repeal and
replace Obamacare I mean is is there
life left in the Republicans effort to
do that at this point it's difficult to
say the thing that we've seen over this
entire six-month healthcare saga is that
for as much as the Republican Party had
a slogan over the last seven years
repeal and replace Obamacare there is no
real consensus about what that meant in
practice did people want that
Republicans want to go back to the pre
Obamacare status quo do they want to
keep some parts of the law and and kind
of get rid of others what direction do
they want to go go through and it's
clear from kind of the repeated failure
and and missteps with these health care
bills and Congress that there is no
consensus here so you can kind of
imagine Republicans making another go at
it trying to advance another bill but
there it's not clear there's a lowest
common denominator
here that everyone can agree to and so I
you know this this but all the health
care bills in their various iterations
have died and come back to life and died
and come back to life so I I'm hesitant
to say that the effort is dead but it is
increasingly clear that unless
Republicans kind of sit down and really
hash out what they want from health care
reform that they're gonna run into the
same problems you know what about the
idea of bipartisan support I mean we
heard from Schumer we heard even from
McCain about this idea of needing to
work together is that just impossible
here I think one of the problems is that
Republicans and Democrats here have
basically fundamentally different goals
I think if Republicans came to Democrats
and said here here are these problems
with the exchanges the subsidy payments
to insurers be more regular there are
there's a subsidy gap for actual
consumers such that if you make a little
too much money you kind of get subsidies
are phased out for you we can fix those
problems and make the exchanges more
stable and this would go towards making
the law more stable in the long run I
think Democrats would accept that but
the problem is that Republicans aren't
interested in making the law stable in
the long run and broadly they're not
interested in the democratic goal of
universal coverage and so because those
goal those are just fundamental divides
here I'm not sure there can be the kind
of bipartisanship that I think people
want just because it's just not the
parties are really on two separate paths
here all right Jamelle Bouie thank you
very much for being with us this morning
thank you for having me